Elon replied my mind is a storm I don't
think most people would want to be me
they may think they would want to be me
but they don't they don't know they
don't understand this is why jealousy is
a stupid emotion Envy it's the only one
of the seven deadly sins which doesn't
actually feel good think about that nval
says about jealousy I realized that all
of these people I was jealous of I
couldn't just cherry-pick and choose
little aspect of their life I couldn't
say I want his body I want her money I
want his personality you have to be that
person do you actually want to be that
person with all of their real actions
their desires their family their
happiness level their outlook on life
their self-image if you're not willing
to do a wholesale 24/7 100% swap with
who that person is then there is no
point in being jealous